sailing into the port of Hamburg because
cargo ships are getting bigger and
bigger the navigation channel of the
Elbe River has been continually deepened
over the past decades Hamburg depends on
trade with countries all over the world
and the threat of US tariffs and
retaliatory measures from the EU could
throttle the volume of its import-export
business it's like filling up your
harbor with rocks to protect the economy
from imports and then the other side
does the same that can't be intelligent
policy it's a mistake to believe that
protectionism is the answer to
protectionism
I think that's reacting to stupidity
with stupidity it might not be a good
idea to call your negotiation partner
stupid especially if it's the US
president so how should you deal with
someone like Donald Trump I put that to
Ralph Brenner who teaches negotiate our
tactics to executives in Hamburg
demister I've never met Trump so I don't
know if he's like this but there is a
type of negotiator who tries to push you
into a corner he wants to see how you
react he tests you and if you pass the
test he'll go on talking with you
otherwise you've lost and if you start
looking down on him you've already lost
that means you have to prepare your
negotiation strategy in such a way that
you encounter him on an equal footing
does that mean taking part in the
exchange of threats and counter threats
where would that lead I've come to meet
Kenan instat CEO of the Hamburg Chamber
of Commerce its premises reflect the
proud tradition of the cities merchant
class
how do you think we should respond to
Trump Europe needs to take a clear stand
we have to say that we won't accept this
kind of thing if only to get Trump to
take us seriously and listen to us but
it's the same time we have to take care
to keep the conversation going because
we can't afford to get sucked into the
spiral of protectionism from which we'll
have trouble
emerging so mr. Shapiro Valley he9
Govardhan that would be the worst thing
for the economy that's where 40 votes
after Ankush limp for now Hamburg and
Germany are not in the line of fire at a
moment the US has China in its sights
the EU has been exempted from the
tariffs for now it seems only the
Chinese are going to be punished should
we be happy about that if we as
Europeans really have free traders our
goal then we can't be happy that Donald
Trump has taken aim quote just at China
unquote and reactivated tariffs that
goes against the fundamental idea of the
World Trade Organization and we
Europeans need to be very cautious
particularly with regard to Donald
Trump's behavior because the World Trade
Organization provides protections for
the weak against the power of the strong
it's their shop we Europeans need that
protection because compared to the US
and China we're small Klein certainly
small if we don't speak with one voice
in economic terms however Europe is
indeed on a par with the US and with
China for trading hubs like Hamburg the
situation remains tense the exemption of
the EU from u.s. tariffs is only
temporary and Trump is unlikely to let
the Europeans off the hook without
getting something in return
you